man nothing was nasty you're one brave
dog dude if we were you we would run for
the hills the very second karela de
Ville came knocking that woman has some
serious issues when it comes to canines
luckily you have Carlos by your side and
he won't let anything happen to you you
guys are best friends after all
but for your sake we just want to warn
you against spending some one-on-one
time with karela de ville no matter how
sweet and innocent she may act Carlos
dogs now in bends love story ended with
a happily ever after but we're still
curious to find out about their next
chapter keep watching to find out how
things will change now that the barrier
has been taken down for good
[Music]
[Applause]
watching The Descendants franchise come
to a close as bittersweet on one hand
we're so happy for mal and Ben they're
going to be exceptional rulers but on
the other hand we're going to miss our
favorite characters way too much we
would love to get a glimpse of mal and
Ben's happily ever after but that's not
the way Disney movies work throughout
the descendants franchise we've seen our
vks blossom into amazing people who know
what's right and what's wrong it's
actually really amazing
which is a total improvement now hasn't
always done what's right but she always
found the way to right her wrongs and
that's exactly what she does at the end
of descendants three throughout the film
now makes it known that she believes
shedding the barrier is the only way to
save Aragon she lies to Evie and her
friends and tricks Emma and her pirates
into helping her beat Audrey by the end
of the movie now has a change of heart
and decides to tell them the truth they
shunned her at first but end up agreeing
with her vision some of the VKS
chose to go back to the Isle so that
they can be with their families and
friends but fortunately the barrier
doesn't stay closed forever when it
comes time for Malin Ben to give the
people of Aradhana speech now tells the
crowd that everyone has both good and
bad inside of them she tells Ben that
she can't be the queen of auradon while
her very own people are locked up on the
Isle
luckily for mal Ben always had a soft
spot for the Isle and it was totally on
board with her plan now brings down the
barrier forming a bridge between the
Isle and our Dom this way people can
come and go as they please but what does
this mean exactly
well for starters things are going to
change and fast one of the biggest
changes will have to do with the
children from the Isle of the Lost
each and every v/k will be allowed to
attend our don prep which will help them
become good people instead of villains I
can't believe I get to live with you in
your very own yeah it's just a little
stir
so in other words headmistress fairy
godmother is going to have her hands
full but hopefully her daughter Jane
will step in and lend a helping hand
while many of the villains will choose
to move to our Don for good others will
want to reside on the Isle but not
before giving it the upgrade it deserves
now that magic is no longer illegal on
the Isle it's people don't have to live
in poverty anymore the aisle will go
from Bora to Sheik in no time but will
always maintain its villainous charm
fruits trees and endless supplies will
pour into the Isle making it a lovely
place to live
now that mal and Ben are the king and
queen of both our Don and the Isle many
changes are going to happen but first
smell and then need to have their royal
wedding and you just know that Evie is
going to design the most beautiful
wedding dress for mal and now that Emma
and now are friends again we wouldn't be
surprised if now asked uma to be one of
her bridesmaids but mal and Ben's
relationship isn't the only one that's
booming after all Evie did wake Doug up
with true love's kiss
so the blueberry princess and Doug are
bound to tie the knot at some point or
another and the same can be said about
Carlos and Jane or should we say jar
lows Jane was so nervous to meet Cruella
De Vil and we can't really blame her can
you imagine having karela as a
mother-in-law but romance isn't the only
thing in store for our favorite BK's
because new friendships are also in
abundance that only RV Ches and ak's
forming new bonds but old rivals are
burying the hatchet
uma and mal are friends again and Jane
Gil might just have the most adorable
bromance of all time we mean they're
going on vacation together that says it
all
and while we're on the subject of aks
and divvy Ches did you guys notice the
sparks between Harry hook and Audrey
clearly Harry was impressed with
Audrey's finesse for evil tantrums and
she seemed to be interested - now that
the barrier is down for good dr. Faso
Leah and Celia are definitely going to
open up a tarot reading shop somewhere
in auradon and they're finally going to
get the cut they deserve you make sure
you get your cut kingpin and Queen mal
will rule over the United States of
auradon and turn VK day into a brand-new
holiday every year they'll celebrate the
day when the barrier was taken down so
there you have it guys the dissidents
three ending in all its glory were you
happy with the way things ended towels
in the comment section and that's a wrap
subscribe to the things if you want more
de video x' to come
your way and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching we'll see you later
[Music]